[Music]
here's how I made my fortune
I started with an orange juice store
[Music]
started with nothing at all
but I'll be coming after me
Over My Dead Body
[Music]
God help me
Lord take me
Christ forgive me
this is how I made
my family
my mom's
create the image
[Music]
God help me
Lord take me
[Music]
Christ forgive me
right strike me down
[Music]
stocks
lost it all
[Music]
thank you
three months
hold up
put on these Nikes
dressed just like me
[Applause]
go in
oh where the marathon leads me
[Music]
pollution
hold on my nose
[Music]
crying
plain white
Rose
oh
God help me
[Music]
Christ forgive me
I lost it all
lost it all
that stops
[Music]
lost it all
moved me
Lord take me
[Music]
stocks
lost it all
[Music]
God help me
God don't strike me down
[Music]
in that thunderstorm
and that Lightning God help me
[Music]
Christ forgive me
thank you